i think i mentioned offline drink vodka
whiskey
sort of alcohol because i don't
feel good about it the day after
or sometimes multiple days after so i
know it's not good for me
so i do a lot of stuff that's good for
me everything we talked about exercise
and diet and all those kinds of things
but the alcohol almost symbolizes
embracing the chaos of life
the the wild and the amazing things that
could happen
and i think that's really important
because if you optimize everything about
life
then you're going to miss most of the
fun stuff that happens in life
so it's not all about the optimization
it's some of it
like everyone has different things on
what they how they introduce that chaos
in a controlled way
for me alcohol is that because i'm okay
drinking not too much
so i can control that aspect even though
it's
unhealthy it introduces just the right
amount of fun
that yeah i embrace it yeah and i mean
it is one of those things where it's
like
i'm gonna benefit now and pay later a
little bit too where like
and hey if you go and you you go out
with some friends and and drink
and you have memories that last a
lifetime from that experience and you
paid for it for a couple days after then
hey maybe that's a
fair trade-off from life experience and
part of the vodka thing is i need to
honor my ancestors
so it's like you have to you know you
can't
you can't turn your back on your past
you